I had a dream that prompted a hilarious
thought is this is such like a weird web
of thinking but someone posted a video
of Dana White's head size lastly what
bring it up dude I have to see this it's
like one of those end of your progress
pigs 2018-2019 I was [ __ ] crying dude
this [ __ ] it's not someone needs to take
that's him yeah oh my god so someone
needs to take talk this [ __ ] you know
like does tick tocks on our like yeah
yeah yeah
let's see dude I don't know if there was
any audio with this I don't think there
is sorry for the people listening no
this is better cuz we won't get in
trouble I couldn't believe this is him
dude yeah that's and then already was
that a year who knows and then he looks
a little bit he looks like a loser here
looks like Lex Luthor it's crazy okay
now it's masking thick and a little bit
more red yeah oh my god dude oh my god
dude it's great
I said what's he yelling about Jesus he
literally said Conor McGregor bro so in
my dream Dana White was we were like
going into some event and he was yelling
at someone and there was like a dress
code for this [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah this was crazy as hell it started
by me standing on a building in a
hurricane okay or like a yeah hurricane
was coming through and but the building
was taller than it and it was like
resistant to it okay so it just like
passed through the building we're just
watching all this [ __ ] get destroyed
like such like some inception bull yeah
okay and then we end up in some
can casino this is get into somewhere is
Dana White and he's like like he's
dressed like black bear
he's got tats like all over his arm okay
he's like an emo who's I painted
fingernails okay and he's screaming at
someone and then he's yelling at us to
put on fake nails is what you and I like
we've got to do a show or some [ __ ] okay
this is clearly like I'm just not
sleeping and I'm just thinking about New
Year's Eve it is with us hanging out
with the [ __ ] like avoid Dana White
and I woke up just like hysterical
thinking about Dana White with like
eyeliner and painted nails in a chain
with a lock on it yeah and like a choker
you know what do you think it means
clearly we're gonna be in the UFC no I
think it means that maybe the UFC needs
some goth energy a goth influence yeah I
would have some kpop influence yes there
you go
yeah well you know we got there needs to
be an e boy Fight League just like chase
Tut ain't in our rabbi kid's name is
yeah just blown hearts at each other
you